(music)
- [Anna Temkin] 1913 was
a banner year for Leger.
It was the year in which he figured out
how to become a Leger
instead of a follower
of Picasso or Braque.
He did a large series
of paintings entitled
Contrast of Form.
Each of these examined
the ways in which these
basic primary and
secondary colors could be
put together with black and white
in order to make a
canvas like, that music,
could be appreciated
without having to read it
as a certain kind of scene or a narrative.
Contrast of Forms, what
does that tell you,
not a whole lot, so what
he's not telling you,
very deliberately, is that this painting
would have been figures and you see these
kind of mechanical shapes,
almost like mannequins
or tin men, that form
these vertical stacks,
very much like bodies.
Like any painter at that time,
Leger would have training from life
to do anatomy.
Now he's trying to put that behind him
trying to turn what might be a rather
calm image into one that almost seems
like a snapshot caught
at an accidental moment
in mid motion.
He wants you to look at this painting
as a painting.
He leaves so much of that
burlappy canvas blank
and raw, those pigments on it, they feel
kind of crusty and almost
like they're put there
not by a painter with a fine brush,
but somebody applying
things in a much more
rugged way, in a much more hands on way.
The white is applied almost like chalk.
It's so rough.
To make this picture pop, an offsetting,
contrast, as Leger knew,
to these reds and blues,
yellows and greens, that would have been
unthinkable in painting a
mere ten years before this.
I bet you when this
painting was put on view
in 1913, most of the
viewers would have thought,
"When is the painter gonna come along
"and turn this sketch into something
"that's actually a final product?"